Micheal Chabon just published this
collection called manhood for amateurs
and at one essay he talks about how when
you look at male culture post 70s post
the sexual revolution it remains a
stultifying monoculture and I thought
that was a really really good way of
putting it you know one thing I've
always found is that a lot of men
particularly like straight men
post-college are very bad at making
friends and I've always felt like I'm an
exception to this because I'm quite
comfortable being weird now you know I
remembering this essay must've been one
of these men's magazines like GQ and the
idea was you know it's weird for you to
be like hey you want a stranger you want
to go watch football of my house later
and it's at you know that's like well
that's odd and so you know you just have
the friends you made in high school or
in college you stick with them for life
and you know women and contrast seam you
know really good at kind of reaching out
to people and that seems like something
that's incredibly counterproductive even
in these narrow economic terms if you
can actually make these new kind of
horizontal connections to people even
though it's totally like horrible
mercenary sense let alone the way in
which you know when you live a life in
isolation or I think about you know men
that I know who've been divorced and you
know the common thread is when you're a
guy and you're you're dating women and
your friends are like always how's that
thing going or how's it going with you
know woman x or when why and you know
that's great and it's like you're able
to kind of strategize and think and like
you know this is it's this tremendously
you know this tremendously strengthening
kind of feeling whereas when people get
married something like we can talk about
that anymore because that suggests that
it's contingent that suggests that it's
a process that it's continuing to be
negotiated and so you can't talk about
it so the fact that you know men
continue to have this kind of solitary
macho you know can't acknowledge
vulnerability or weakness attitude I
think is actually undermining in all
kinds of ways you know leaving aside
psychological health you know also
professional health you need people that
you can plot and scheme with and when
you don't have that you know given the
new environment in which again
resiliency is at a premium you're doomed
so if that's what the death of macho
means and I think that it is what it
means in part that's a really really
good thing
that's a really really good point this
is something I've talked to a lot of my
friends about you know a friend of mine
matt crawford wrote a wonderful book
called a shop class a soul craft and the
argument is that you know men
traditionally had opportunities to work
with their hands and to you know
cultivate a different kind of skill or
intelligence in their daily life of
problem-solving intelligence and that in
the modern workplace where abstracted
from this in a way that is in kind of
deeply undermining of certain kind of
masculine virtues and I do buy that
although I do wonder also if you know I
think that women also you know kind of
have a need for this kind of problem
solving intelligence oh it's not
particularly men though I think it might
be particularly impactful of men given
that again this kind of emotional
component is often absent or kind of not
present in the same ways so yeah I
definitely I think my dream is an
economy in which people are really
cultivating what is their true
competence a world in which you know
kind of we're not all part of the same
status hierarchies or you know everyone
has kind of decent enough living so that
you don't feel as though well I have to
kind of compete to work this job that I
hate so that I can live in a school
district you know kind of where my
children will not be kind of savagely
beaten to death by hooligans and then
you know I can take chances I can like
make things I can you know be truly
entrepreneurial I don't have to feel
like I have to kowtow to someone this
idea of you know American culture at its
best being something about cell starting
that's really appealing and I do think
that has something to do with a
masculine ideal so I buy that but again
when you look at the guys you know kind
of in this kind of blue-collar universe
you know who were the kind of happiest
people I mean they had incredibly
fulfilling relationships with kind of
other people doing their work they were
relationships built on collaboration so
I think that we could have a
constructive mix